bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler d'un téléphone que j'ai vu sur le
mwc
alors je commence par introduire un peu
la vidéo et après on va filer ensemble
directement au mwc
je vous explique le truc est quand même
assez hallucinant quand j'étais là-bas
j'ai déjà testé en premier smartphone du
lait phone ils m'ont dit attendez
attendez attendez on en a un deuxième
qui est super vous allez voir c'est un
super produit c'est un peu comme
l'iphone qui est génial il donc fait moi
voir ça donc il me donne le smartphone
je commence à le tester et là je pose ma
caméra
je commence mon test ce que vous allez
voir avec le temps et plus la vidéo
avance et plus je me rends compte que
téléphone qui devrait qu'il l'ait
vraiment être une bombe atomique
en fin de compte il est vraiment
vraiment vraiment pas terrible voire
même carrément douteux peut-être est-ce
des petits défauts du constructeur
peut-être qu'ils ont été un peu léger
sur le stand toujours est il que vous
allez vous rendre compte valoir notre
honte
au début je commence je suis plutôt
enthousiaste joaillier cool ce téléphone
et à la fin c'est pas ça du tout je vous
laisse regarder et vous me dites tout ce
que vous en pensez en commentaire on y
va
[Musique]
ce smartphone c'est le mulet phone t2
pro d2 pro jolie appellation en tout cas
ce qui est intéressant avec ce
smartphone c'est effectivement le très
grand écran 19/9 6 7 pouces fhd plus de
1160 par 1080 pixels
côté processeur vous avez un et llopez
70 en cas d'accord 8 gigas de ram 128
giga de stockage double caméra à
l'arrière 21 mégapixels et 13 mégapixels
une caméra à l'avant de 16 mégapixels
une batterie de 5000 milliampères heures
et tout ça ça tourne vous en aurez au
8.1 alors sans papiers on se dit que
c'est une bête de compet on se dit que
c'est une bête de course
en tout cas on le prenait en main je
trouve qu'il est pas mal attention parce
que là quand je le prends en main il a
un don en plastique à l'arrière il ya eu
effectivement il a souffert de personnes
qui n'ont pas fait très très attention
et il est complètement éclatée rayé je
sais pas si vous le voyez bien derrière
ils m'ont assuré que sur le prochain
smartphone android ont envers beaucoup
plus solide en attendant c'est un
produit qui est super fin qui a un côté
chrome est plutôt pas mal
vous avez de l'usb type c'est ici son
côté ici vous avez un bouton pour
l'allumer le bouton volume pas deux
prises jack sort ce smartphone là c'est
bien dommage
votre lecteur de carte sim qui se trouve
ici bon je trouve qu'il est pas mal
c'est vrai qu' on est vraiment sur un
bord à bord on a un très léger bord
métal sur le côté c'est pas vraiment
dérangeante aucun ne s'impose pas de
problème c'est vrai que l'écran est
grand
l'écran est beau il tient bien dans la
main et vous avez en plus c'est un truc
est super intéressant mais je ne peux
pas tester tout de suite ça c'est
vraiment vraiment dommage c'est une
reconnaissance d'empreintes digitales
placé directement dans l'écran
il n'assure que ça marche de toute façon
j'ai pas le choix que l'écran sur parole
mais c'est quand même un peu frustrant
parce que quand on a des techno comme ça
on a effectivement envie de pouvoir les
tester directement
normalement vous positionnez votre doigt
la ja déverrouiller votre smartphone
on nous annonce également du fays heidi
et leur fait ça dit
on l'aura pas vous avez une seule caméra
à l'avant c'est une reconnaissance
d'image
je pense effectivement via l'appareil
photo il va reconnaître votre visage ira
le scanner pas en trois dimensions et
pas de caméra trouvait le là dedans
c'est très clair par contre c'est un
déverrouillage à ses standards je trouve
que dans tous les produits chinois que
j'ai vu c'est un produit qui est super
séduisant j'ai un bémol quand même sur
la solidité on dit qu'on va changer
qu'on aura du verre à l'arrière savez ce
qu'on dit à les écrire et à ses paroles
s'envolent très probablement je ne sais
pas en attendant l'écran est assez beau
c'est du lcd ça marche plutôt pas mal
rien à reprocher ils sont ces coups ici
sur le stand parce que vous avez les
smartphones qui n'ont pas de protection
sont posés comme ça on pourrait presque
bar avec c'est
très très très très très cool en
attendant je pense que voilà c'est un
produit qui est pas mal
l'écran est jolie il se tient bien ça va
devoir trouver sur internet sur amazon
ou autour des 400 dollars dites moi ce
que vous en pensez comme moi vous
trouvez ça va être plus en plus de
constructeurs chinois qui vont arriver
en france avec des produits plus ou
moins bien fini mais en attendant c'est
vrai que pour un produit à 400 euros 400
dollars par don vous avez un truc qui
est quand même super impressionnant
petite info en plus je ne terminais ma
vidéo j'étais en train de faire quelque
chose que vous présenter le produit là
qu'est ce qui se passe je m'active et la
caméra est là la caméra me crachent le
téléphone donc plus du tout de téléphone
puis axa rien téléphone noir et on me
dit ah ben non mais la caméra marche
pareil voilà il faut redémarrer le
téléphone il faut faire un reboot
c'est assez compliqué si vous voulez
parce que vous retrouvez avec un produit
qui effectivement vous avez une idée d
une possibilité de déverrouiller
directement sur l'écran vous pouvez pas
testé avec un dos en plastique qui
cassent et en vous décrivant un dos en
verre vous l'essayez caméra la caméra ne
marche pas et ensuite dans différentes
applications ont mené que google a
craché bien que ce soit un proto c'est
bien que ce soit pas le modèle fini qui
a encore pas mal de boulot mais je les
admire moins compliqué vous voulez parce
que en termes de confiance en la marque
on est sur un salon comme ça qu'un salon
pro que le produit crash que les caméras
ne marche pas que le produit cas c'est
que je trouve un petit peu la coulée la
dilettante
avec des smartphones et par exemple
aucune attache bon pour moi en terme de
confiance c'est zéro pointé dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en commenter à ce qui
pourrait vous intéresser
j'ai hâte de lire vos commentaires merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé la vidéo comme
d'habitude vous invite à laisser les
jeunes poussent à rester connectés
il y aura plein d'autres vidéos sans fin
de produits par intéressant donc rester
avec moi à très bientôt
ciao ciao portez vous bien de sa vie
[Musique]